okay guys here's a couple gradual
bubbles with bacon eggs over-medium the
side of fruit enjoy what
look at my fruit ball trying to have
football center here and this is no
herons they always do this it's too much
honey - what's wrong honey dear what's
wrong with honey do everything
everything's wrong with honey do name
literally one thing oh my god
I will mean several things okay uh one
it tastes like butt - it's never right
oh you know a butt case because I have
one can you eat it yes three look at how
much space is taking up it's it's a
filler fruit where's the cantaloupe
where's the pineapple right these are
the strawberry why there's one grape in
here one great in a while
ten pieces of honeydew I'm so sorry just
pick around it take around it just pick
around it there is no picking around it
it is it I made the mature responsible
adult choice of ordering a side of fruit
instead of ordering a side of potatoes
and in return I get boned with a [ __ ]
honeydew platter with a side of go [ __ ]
yourself it's it's like when bartenders
put more ice in your drink so that you
think you're getting more alcohol I'm
not getting more alcohol I know I just
wait
hey he's everything okay I know I
displacement works
oh my god um I'm sorry it's it's not you
it's it's the honeydew all right I get
it
you do you think I enjoy this
they make us put extra honey doing here
because it's cheaper I go home every
night discussed it with the man that
I've become a honeydew peddler
you know you know sometimes I go to the
bridge downtown take a pebble off the
edge of the bridge and just see how far
it'll fall and wonder to myself what if
there was a way to just end it all [ __ ]
on you to [ __ ]
honeydew I like all other fruits and
that for sure is true but on one thing
we can all agree [ __ ]
honeydew spa honeydew honeydew this
[ __ ] nothing good about I just wanna
shout it
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you back but
honey
[Music]
I'm not even hungry anymore can we go
yeah I'm Nadia recently no I think I
need is actually pretty delicious